you think a depressed person could make  this life is pointless and nothing  matters and i'm always tired  [Music]  she drove me here who hasn't had gay  thoughts stay back [ __ ] this just says i  can do what i want  i'm dead there's like a 30 chance  they'll both die  it's about the cones no just stop  pooping the calzones  betrayed me places outstanding thank you  alcohol  boom  sadness  no thinking just stupid never half-ass  two things  whole ass one thing buttery's my  favorite food mommy please  no tragically we are both heterosexual  just give me all the bacon and eggs you  have i regret nothing the end i know  what i'm about son i really needed this  i am super chill all the time